republican senator mike braun yesterday
said he would be okay
putting the issue of interracial
marriage back to the states rather than
the supreme court decision which
bans bans on interracial marriage
holding he would be fine canceling that
and letting states decide do you want
interracial marriage to be legal or do
you want interracial marriage to be
illegal this understandably created a
firestorm because it's a crazy thing to
say let's look at the clip here is uh
mike braun so you would be okay with the
supreme court leaving the question of
interracial marriage to the states
yes i think that that's something that
uh if you're not wanting the supreme
court to weigh in
on issues like that
you're not going to be able to have your
cake and eat it too i think that's
hypocritical
about griswold versus connecticut well
you can list a whole host of issues so
he very clearly heard the question
and the point here is many republicans
like mike braun like to say
the supreme court really shouldn't
decide about all sorts of things the
supreme court shouldn't decide that
abortion generally speaking should be
legal it should just be up to the states
the supreme court shouldn't decide that
states aren't allowed to ban same-sex
marriage and so it's a reasonable
question which is would you also apply
to this to interracial marriage should
states be allowed to ban interracial
marriage he clearly heard the question
and answered it unfortunately for him
this was a completely outrageous thing
to say
and he had to later walk it back
claiming he didn't hear the question
braun walks back remark criticizing the
supreme court ruling that legalized
interracial marriage and you've got to
go to the bottom of the article on the
hill in a statement to the hill later
tuesday bronze said he misunderstood
the question as posed
earlier during a virtual press
conference i misunderstood a line of
questioning that ended up being about
interracial marriage let me be clear on
that issue there is no question the
constitution prohibits discrimination of
any kind based on race that is not
something that is even up for debate i
condemn racism in any form at all levels
and by any states entities or
individuals
so um uh claiming claiming he just
didn't even really know what he was
being asked now there is a very
important legal conversation to have
about when should states be left to
decide about whatever and not all of
these issues are created equal when you
say well leave states to decide about
abortion well okay the supreme court put
in place this undue burden test that's
the the basis of casey casey is the
court the decision in addition to roe v
wade
uh you've got casey and there the court
put in place this uh undue burden
standard which says that abortion
restrictions
are unconstitutional if the purpose or
effect places a substantial obstacle in
the path of women who want to get an
abortion so that that's one decision and
one sort of framework uh leave states to
decide about do you have to have car
insurance
most states say you do
virginia and new hampshire have
different rules like in new hampshire
car insurance isn't mandatory
but if you're driving causes damages
then you're liable and that's a decision
that a state has made
leave states to decide about should
marijuana be legal and can be purchased
just like cigarettes or alcohol well for
now states can decide about that if the
federal government were to
in some way
fully legalize marijuana
um
reschedule it okay then you would sort
of have a fight when it comes to the
decision about interracial marriage the
supreme court said no no no there's a
constitutional basis here equal the
equal protection clause
if properly scrutinized as the supreme
court did
doesn't allow states to ban interracial
marriage you can't leave it to the
states because of the federal supremacy
clause and the fact that banning
interracial marriage would violate the
federal constitution so the framework is
very different than some of these other
decisions so the point here is
even if there is a legitimate debate to
be had about
what should states have to decide about
interracial marriage is outside of that
and uh i don't believe mike braun
misheard it nor misunderstood it i think
he just gave the wrong answer it was
just wrong and it was crazy and he got
called out for it and he had to walk it
back
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite
magic spoon lets you enjoy a sweet
delicious snack without the guilt you
can stick to your goals and still treat
yourself and if you don't love magic
spoon as much as i do they'll give you
all of your money back no questions
asked magic spoon is giving my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
and use the promo code pacman